oh hey I came ready I brought my own
apron Bri a welcome to worth it
lifestyle okay yep you're obviously a
very talented cook thank you that's why
you're here on what the lifestyle we're
doing kitchen knives
yes Wow Hey Hey nice necklace I am a
very amateur home cook but I know that
you not only are a great home cook you
worked in professional kitchens and also
I used to work for a knife company as a
knife sales by saying I would like to
take you to my old stomping ground all
right let's stop once on the grounds
then let's go
welcome to the show Rea thank you your
first time as the featured sole host
usually you're our translator a cultural
guide parfait ambassador bodyguard
everybody needs a ring in their life oh
that's the best thing do you ever said
to me
best thing today I'm worth it lifestyle
we're gonna be trying three kitchen
knives at three drastically different
place points to find out which one is
the most worth it at his price what
we're on our way right now to a company
called portal II bamboo and they are
making lettuce knives so I've never
heard a lettuce knife I've never seen a
knife made oh he's bamboo does it work
is it sharp
Hot Shot knife
hi my name is Tom Sullivan and I'm
Joanne Sullivan and we're co-owners of
totally bamboo and today we'd like to
show you our lettuce knife
what makes bamboos so great as the
sustainable material bamboo grows to
maturity in four years the pole itself
will die at seven years so we're not
taking anything away from nature also
bamboo you don't have to water it or
fertilize it it just grows and if you
don't use it it will die we're using the
same mountains that they use for
centuries it's the same place that
chopsticks and the Ming Dynasty were
made out of it's really neat it's a very
romantic way of thinking we kept
experimenting with what can we do
differently and laser was one of the
early ones we'd landed on because that's
just a way to make a cutting board a
piece of artwork we saw so many lettuce
knives on the market that we just
figured we need a bamboo one there's too
many plastic ones plastic of course is
plastic it's it's not biodegradable it
doesn't have the the looking feel of the
natural material we developed ours with
a nice ergonomic thick handle pretty
excited how we we got the little grooves
on the wood which is something unique
because it's woodworking we had to
develop a special jig that would make
those grooves it's all handmade we're
really not a giant production so this
knife what do you think it's super light
oh wow it's like a feather don't do that
okay
let's fly in the lettuce Andrew you
ready to cut yeah
can you first teach me how to cut
lettuce I feel like there's no right way
it's almost look like you break her at
the scene aha Oh like a strong person
just busted it open so have you ever had
to tear lettuce by hand in a kitchen
before yeah so usually when you're at
the follow the station you hand at all
with us like that kind of looks prettier
I feel like this knife kind of gives the
same effect it's good this is how my
mouth looks after I eat
like a baby this bamboo species that
they're using is not the bamboo that
feeds pandas in China they are no
skating pond that's food yes
don't steal paint as good this a knife
it's great because it's slated when
you're cutting something it's not about
strength I just think I think it's like
fruit ninja the cabbage up never do it
no okay
totally bamboo yeah it was such a nice
couple starting business together yes
their passion about bamboo it's
extraordinary
you ready for the next stop we a we're
going to touch a knife at town get to
knife back hotel mama to ski but jomama
to ski in medieval times people would
bring daggers to the table when they ate
do you know why they are afraid of
somebody try to attack them yes part of
the reason yes and the other reason is
to cut the food oh yeah can I just point
out flower blooming Wow deform
California today good thing we are now
leaving beautiful California going to
Koren knives in New York City I used to
work there at the knife salesperson I
sold very expensive knife as a gift for
you what I'm not sure we can say that he
is a very talented musician yes cellist
[Music]
my name is Vincent and I'm the sharpener
here at Corrin Japanese trading I think
you guys know each other
yeah and what were you doing here I was
a salesperson I visit restaurants and so
table wares or night sometimes we tag
along together and show how to shut the
knife properly to cooks and chefs in the
kitchen the owner here sorry : oh she
started as a business way back in 1982
she was actually waitressing at first
and she saw a demand for Japanese
tableware in these restaurants cuz they
were using really cheap almost imitation
stuff the nice we carry are really
geared for professional use so it's all
handcrafted in Japan Japanese knives are
more delicate because they're so sharp
it's thin and light my mentor Chi
harvester guy he started sharpening and
the service for our customers so that
they had a place to go and you know
repair their knives the craftsmanship
and the skill and experience that goes
into each and every knife really
produces a knife that's sharper and it's
gonna hold its edge a lot longer when
you have a dull knife and you're trying
to cut something you're forcing the
knife through you can easily slip and
hurt yourself so having a struck knife
it does less damage to the cell
structure of the ingredient it just
makes the food taste better when you're
cutting onion if you're using sharp our
knife it doesn't make it classically we
have the option of what we call the
initial sharpening a knife is ready to
use out of the box but it's always good
to touch it up just a little bit more to
give it that extra little sharpness we
can do that service for you as well so
the knife we have here today is the Toki
hogwash santoku it's something that's a
little bit unique western edge or a
double bevel knife which makes it very
versatile but it has a traditional
Japanese handle on it so it takes the
best of both world and put it together
it's just amazing that no matter you
know how far we are from New York people
still recognize us that's a nice sound
cut this fits my hand very well I like
to round our handle how are you how are
you holding your knife so you kind of
put your index finger and thumb in here
so it's secure and very sturdy what do
you want a cup for let's do the what's
the easy thing the cut here Apple first
it's a nice
whoa it does feel really satisfying to
have my force transmitted so easily
through the Apple should I try to cut
like this cut the core out I feel like
the way you are holding knife scared of
me somehow like this thing like
something about I don't know what to
tell you teach me how to cut this just
show me okay well now I'm like getting
nervous cuz I'll do it really slowly you
still nervous a little bit there we go
no why everybody's freaking out I
remember the person I cut a tomato
it's flattered so tomato um it's the
inside it's soft so it's very difficult
to cut if you have dull life so let's
see how sharp it is enough it whoa Wow
that's what you're talking about just
like so I've seen on YouTube people are
cutting tomato very thing and I want to
challenge you
we can peel the tomato skin that's nice
wow oh wow oh wow okay Bri a can even
see through it oh my god that was boring
it's Corinne the knife was so sharp
watch out
I did feel like because it was sharper
it was safer yeah and it made my mind
sharper knife that hot gentlemen
Matushka throw mama just be okay Rhea
yes how many knife related injuries are
treated in the US every day on average
mm no if it more it's less than that
it's 1190 have you ever had a knife for
the injury before yes so I cut my finger
weeds bread knife before
no oh please ha it's I was bleeding
everywhere
alright 3a so finally for our last stop
we're gonna stay in New York City to see
some very unique nice try another knife
fun nice bomb is a friend to buy and
real nice knowing you
I'm Chelsea Miller and I'm a knife maker
and we are in my home in Clinton Hill
Brooklyn and I have my little backyard
knife studio which I'm going to show you
how long have you been a knife maker for
I've been a knife maker since the end of
2011 but I also grew up in very rural
Vermont and my father was a blacksmith
so it's always been in my blood from a
very young age what inspired you and
what inspires tiffin eyes that you make
now so when I first started making
knives I was very much in a place where
I wanted to just bring everything back
to me so the metal I ended up using for
a nut my knife was recycled from a
horseshoe rasp which we'd grown up with
all our lives my dad had horses the high
carbon steel which is great for knife
making because it holds a great edge and
it's easy to sharpen and then all the
wood that I use for the handles comes
from the trees on my parents farm and a
lot of the wood that my dad had cut and
has been drying for you know 30 years
just sitting there once I have the
material I have a plasma cutter where I
can cut out the exact shape of whatever
knife I'm making so after I've cut out
the shape then I take it to my bench
grinder and I just start grinding away
the excess material then I use a series
of belts in different grits so a really
coarse grit to take off more material
and then the grits get finer and finer
on the belts to refine and polish the
Blaz it's a look most importantly I want
your fingers as far away from this wheel
as possible this will be spinning and
you're just going to press against it
this is gonna go like this
okay I'm gonna and keep your elbows
close to your waist and if you feel
comfortable you can just use that as a
little pressure alright
okay I feel alive
often times people want a handmade knife
because of that story and because they
know exactly start to finish the process
that went into the knife like I want to
create something that has value in your
own mind something that is not
unattainable for everyone but it's
something that is a commitment I want to
cut with this oh oh and then also with
this grater
it's kind of like nice way - mm-hmm
did you hold it not yet oh I can go into
battle with this so it's a beautiful
knife it looks amazing but how or does
it cut wow it's very sharp do you know
how to dye seungyun yes wait but do I do
it the right way
probably not it sounds amazing by the
way
why so far away thank you oh wow it
feels like it was made with purpose mhm
it's giving me purpose no yeah-oh shop
knife don't make you cry I would love to
try this thing something that is so cool
to have this on a knife yeah have you
seen this before
no this knife is not gonna get there tsa
so we'll leave it here in New York
tell us whose knife yes what do you
think it was beautiful I want to be that
woman who used the knife in a beautiful
kitchen cooking rustic so we've now
covered three knives what's the most
worth it to you and I know we're gonna
pick what go ahead okay my wall cent
winner is Corinne that knife reads very
sharp you can use for everything and
it's not too expensive you know I also
feel like that knife is kind of you
Japanese knife came to America
multi-purpose what multiple purposes
that's true so the bamboo knife very
sustainable and also innovative mm-hmm
and really cheap my worth it winner
today
orange yeah I think the thing about it
is is it inspires me to cook you don't
take corners
okay so that's been worth it lifestyle
Rea thank you for being a wonderful host
thank you so much for having me and a
cool ride or co-writer wait you know
what I'm talking about like the
motorcycle has a little car cool pile of
copilot alright see you next week I'm
worth it lifestyle Roo doing eggs
headphones